you're being over optimistic and you
don't want to scare us so you're trying
to do something but let me give you the
preview we're going to see you in 90
days and you're gonna be on the other
side of this so you're going to have to
admit to the problem and everyone at
this table besides me cuz I'm ridiculous
but the rest of the people here are much
more straight and they're going to be
pissed so why don't you just tell us
that shit's [__] up now and let us
help you for the next 40 minutes instead
of saying it's all good because to your
point this let me hold it in and maybe
I'll make it work by the time I see them
and 90 days when you see them in 90 days
and it's double bad AKA you didn't say
[__] 90 days ago and now you're saying
it's an 11 out of 10 issue whereas 90
days ago you were saying it's all fine
AKA it's a zero or a one or two out of
10 you're in deep [__] cuz you've lost
Trust of the board and that's when the
seeds start to sprout of are you the
right person to run this company
attention is the number one
asset vayer Nation how are you another
exciting episode of the Gary audio
experience decided that we've done a lot
of motivation we're doing a lot of
innovation but I want to get into
operation I want to get into the depths
uh I was really excited when the
opportunity came to have this guest on
the show because I think bringing
leaders who actually did it are actually
doing it are are Building B you know for
me building a business that from afar I
admire in its longevity it's not a fly
by night it's not a quote unquote
unicorn even though this is probably a
unicorn in the way but it's defied but
like you know like it's it's not it's a
unicorn AKA startup that's a big company
not a rhinoceros with a unicorn with
painting its horn and making pretend
it's a unicorn AKA a lot of the startups
that are grossly overvalued and then
disappear off the face of the Earth
because they were overleveraged and
weren't actually building an actual
business and I want to tap into some of
the minds of the people that are doing
it because so many of you are on your
journey of doing it and so that's why I
asked Henry to be on the show Henry
welcome please tell everybody your full
name what you do what the company is and
a little bit about the company and I
think we should get into a meat and
potatoes episode here of the audio
experience thank you for being on
brother yeah thanks Gary thanks for
having me yeah my name's Henry Ward I'm
the uh co-founder CEO at Carta uh you
know we do we're about 10 years old we
uh do we have three lines of business uh
we're about 350 million in Revenue about
60% of that comes out of our cor cap
table business which where we serve
startups and manage their cap tables uh
the another 30% comes out of our uh fund
Administration business where we manage
the back office of venture funds and do
their their financial accounting and
reporting to to their investors their
LPS and then we have a a newer uh
business which is about 10% uh of the
business now it's a couple years old and
it's our private Equity business where
we're we're basically managing the cap
tables and fund Administration for
private Equity um companies and and
funds
how did it
start you know we we saw this Capt
problem it was sort of interesting um
people in 200 you know 1314 when we
launched were were physically mailing
Paper Stock certificates like like if
you see the old movies with the the yeah
with the railroads brother look at this
this oh you've got four in your room
yeah Facebook Twitter and tumblr
beautiful beautiful all pre pre- Carta
uh 20 fall
20067 nice nice really nice you know
what the valuations of those companies
was back then totally totally and
they're beautiful they're embroidered
you know they look exactly like the
stock certificates when they invested in
the railroads and uh and and we were
still doing that in 2013 uh and we said
hey can we do something like what PayPal
did for cash you know can we
dematerialize these stocks for de Vegas
instead of um sending paper uh instead
of paying you know mailing a check or
mail in cash uh could we um send Equity
through through email the way PayPal uh
sent money through email can we can we
do that through the cloud and that was
the original idea uh uh could we push
all this stuff in the cloud and then
once you did that once you
dematerialized uh equity and put it in
the cloud um suddenly the option value
on that exploded you know there's so
many things we could do we could do cap
table management we could do option
management we could do portfolio
management we could do liquidity we
could do fund Administration it just it
it took off we entire ecosystem once
once you got things out of
paper how quickly did you know this is a
great question for the audience how
quickly did you know we got something
here you know we were in beta I think we
kind of launched a free version of this
product maybe in July of
2013 I'm starting to interrupt I
remember it vividly I was so pumped it
existed that's awesome the con the
concept that I was able to just forward
it to somebody be like take care of this
and like the thing I needed to be done
when I was making an investment was done
it was massive for me someone like me
that cares about time over everything
like it was hu I remember those early
days like I was like I remember thinking
like this just changed my
life totally totally well thank you for
being an early user it was it was um you
know it was a tough start like a lot of
these companies where you're doing
something completely new you know nobody
had bought C Capt software before 2014
uh it just didn't exist you know there
there's companies where you're building
something that already exists like like
mongodb is like my favorite example
right people had databases mongodb was
like I'm I'm building a better database
and you didn't have to convince people
to buy a database you just had to
convince people to buy a better database
uh and and cap tables was different
nobody ever in the history of the world
had ever bought a cap table uh software
product before and so you had to
convince people to buy something that
they never bought before uh and they
never thought they needed and so it was
hard to get going you know it's hard to
convince people to do something they've
never done
um and we launched kind of an early beta
in July 2013 that barely worked uh uh
and then we started charging in in
January of 2014 that's when we're like
okay and we earned our first $120 on
January 7th from uh a friend and Company
startup in Austin Texas uh uh and it was
amazing it was incredible the first time
you you build something as an
entrepreneur that somebody pays you for
is a magical moments I'll never it
really you know what that's a great call
out I I I genuinely remember like the
first Gillette deal with fer media AJ
was still in college I vividly remember
kind of the first things I sold at my
dad's liquor store when I was 15 Kenwood
1992 1990 Chardonnay like literally I
can sit here and tell you Kenwood
chardonay from Sonoma Valley is like
ingrained in my heart this goes a little
bit to why I want this episode Henry I
view you from afar and we're getting to
know each other a little bit here as a
like an actual entrepreneur and what I
mean by that is it's in when you like
love the game not the thing that has
become which is like it's so cool like
quote unquote everyone is you know like
I love playing sports but I'm not a
professional athlete when you love the
game like you can like I don't think a
lot of people can actually talk about
the first thing they
sold the modern entrepreneur right like
yeah they can remember when they raised
the capital
they can remember this that the other
thing but like the actual first client
especially if they're five seven years
in in this new era but I can remember
the first wi is sold for my dad the
first client bner media had like all of
it like
vividly totally totally it's it's
amazing I I remember we made $800 in
January of 2014 and it was the most
amazing $800 you know we made this year
we'll put a $100 million of bookings on
the board right but and and the thing is
is even at you know uh 2,000 employees
uh you know 350 million in Revenue going
to
450 uh I spent you know half my day I
talked to four customers yesterday that
were unhappy and that's what you do
that's no different than when you're a
seed founder like you're just if you
love The Game you love talking to
customers look right now back to your
point three hold am I right about this
3:45 pm today client issue I have 2,000
employees how many employees you got
about 2 also yeah there you go right
it's amazing keep going yeah no and and
and you know so so you know at January
we made 800 bucks we're like okay well
at least somebody will pay us for this
so that that was amazing so that was I
guess Milestone one somebody paid us for
something we built uh which was which
was a super huge high and then I would
say that the second one um uh was August
of that year and we we we moved our you
know know back then you still called you
know to to order something you know uh
and so we had a phone system and it was
was one of these things you called in
and you pressed you know one to talk to
sales two to talk to you know support
and we changed our phone system and
broke something so that when you clicked
one and it went to sales it hung up on
you uh you know the classic startup
story like we had no idea what we're
doing and uh so it just hung up on on
you if you tried to talk to a
salesperson and we sold more in August
than we did any month prior and we
didn't even know until halfway through
the month somebody C went in through
support and was like hey guys I'm trying
to give you money to buy your software
and I can't get to anybody you know what
is going on over there and I was like oh
we have something people are beating
down the doors uh uh to get this product
and I would say the third one was we
finally had so many sales orders we
couldn't onboard them fast enough and
this was in uh January of 2014 a year
later sorry December of 2014 and we're
going to Christmas uh and I told the
sales team uh all five or six of them at
the time I said you have to stop selling
you're not allowed to sell uh I'm going
to put you on a draw for for three
months and all of you are going to be
onboarding managers and we're going to
close the doors because our customers
are Furious because they bought but we
can't deliver yeah because we're selling
too much and that was that was the
moment do you yeah do you think that
that is an incredible common mistake of
successful
like obviously a lot of people end up
figuring it out like I actually think
the story you just
told if you even have the talent and the
product Market fit to get to that
problem you 7.5 out of 10 times know
what to do in that moment to get to the
next place sometimes technolog is not
there you might remember frster because
you're a tech dude you know like frster
being down all the time really
eliminated it from having the
opportunity of becoming Myspace or
Facebook right I mean Twitter got lucky
a little bit because there was no unique
competitor there was pounce if you
remember um that PO for a while but but
I mean Twitter was a real problem in
2006 s eight just wasn't up y then
there's the other thing like underd
delivering on what you so big issue for
me in a client service business because
I'm completely human based you have a
smart business I have a stupid business
if I wasn't building something bigger on
top of it and so you know I think I
think for us it's very hard when you're
scaling people as you can imagine with
technology uh or product it's a lot
quote unquote easier when you get your
supply chain or your Tech team down but
do you find that to be a common problem
and then more importantly for the people
that are in it right now that problem
like you've over promised and underd
delivered do you recommend they take
your track which is a drastic T tack or
do you feel like they should do things
that have worked for me in the past
which was more of a okay [__] it I'm
just going to hold my breath and fly the
pl keep flying the plane but fix it
while I'm flying the plane and make sure
that doesn't get out of whack both
what's your thoughts on that yeah well
so we did this uh uh you know we didn't
really have marketing back then so our
our version of marketing was me uh and I
and and my assistant and or chap of
staff I think and I asked my cha staff I
said hey go talk to 50 customers and
interview them and ask them how they
heard about Carta uh why they decided to
buy Carta and what that sales cycle was
like and all of them kind of heard a
little bit different somebody came in
from a friend an investor Google search
whatever it was but the one thing that
was 100% consistent 50 of 50 uh
customers uh asked somebody else who was
a Carta user if they had what they had
heard of Carta uh to decide whether to
buy and so we knew that the most
important thing we could get right is
that when that phone call happened the
the the person who did have experience
with carda would say a good thing that
was like the number one thing nothing
else mattered uh and so so I said it
doesn't matter as we have to make sure
that the reference checks go well and if
people aren't happy it it kills
everything and I'm willing to take you
know a three-month uh uh closing the
doors on sales uh to make sure that's
always true and it was a tough decision
right you know to tell the board hey I'm
not gonna sell for three months that's a
tough tough conversation to have segue
back to like me wanting it to be a meat
and potatoes table talk to me about the
pros and cons not just from your
perspective because you have yours and
obvious there's been a lot of success
congratulations so I have a funny
feeling people are feeling pretty decent
on the board uh at least at this point
but tell the kids or the ogs I I'll tell
you who's a big listener to this Henry
that I think we can inspire a 47 yearold
very successful corporate player who she
or he feels they're ready they're ready
and because they've been successful for
25 years in that environment are going
to actually have like a real board and
real investors right talk me through
your perspective effective but more but
more importantly I was going to say
equally but I'll actually say more
important because and Through The Eyes
of many of the founders you've been
around over the last 15 years the watch
outs and the ways to best use a board
let's do that yeah so I have two tips on
this that have worked well for me so one
is you know the boards are always hungry
for information they want to know what's
going on you know Etc uh and one of my
favorite lines from the Ben Horowitz
book is you know apply pressure either
feel pressure apply pressure and I think
you know he's really talking about
executive teams when the exec teams are
like hounding the CEO and the CEO's like
oh my God I don't know what to do you
know everyone's on me I feel so much
pressure he's like turn the tables apply
pressure or feel it I think that's true
with the board and so I used to tell the
board you know hey I want to put you to
work uh and we had a what's called an
adopted business unit program where I'd
have the the board each board member
would like pick a business unit so I'd
have Matt you know work on cap tables
and I have Mike work with the liquidity
team team and they'd meet with the team
once or twice a month and it was great
because one they helped me they helped
scale me in terms of the strategy and
and sort of influencing the organization
I could run a flatter organization that
way and two when when the board meetings
came up they all had firsthand data it
wasn't just me try to explain everything
like everybody kind of had data so when
they're like Henry what's going on with
the liquidity business I'd be like Mike
what's going on with the liquidity
business you know um and so so it it
really brought them brought them in the
the second thing I would say is um the
gold to you know the the number one rule
on on boards is don't surprise them like
that's just it like as long as you never
surprise the board you'll you'll be okay
uh and so that takes a lot that is the
classic mistake that very
entrepreneurial de someone like me who
would be like I'll figure it like never
had a board before like I and I I I
really don't have board life the where
because I knew that this would be a huge
mistake of mine and ironically I'm on
boards and I help the Gary in that
situation I see the C's doing the
mistake I would make and I make it safe
for her or him be like hey I know what
you're doing it's okay because I don't
want to be a hypocrite I do this [__]
all the time you're being over
optimistic and you don't want to scare
us so you're trying to do something but
let me give you the preview we're GNA
see you in 90 days and you're gonna
you're gonna be on the other side of
this so you're gonna have to admit to
the problem and everyone at this table
besides me because I'm ridiculous but
the rest of the people here are much
more straight and they're going to be
pissed so why don't you just tell us
that shit's [__] up now and let us
help you for the next 40 minutes instead
of saying it's all good because to your
point and this was I'm glad you went
there because I really want to give you
the I'm on the podcast all the time I
can put out content to these people all
the time I want them to hear different
voices this let me hold it in and maybe
I'll make it work by the time I see them
in 90 days when you see them in 90 days
and it's double bad AKA you didn't say
[__] 90 days ago and now you're saying
it's an 11 out of 10 issue whereas 90
days ago you were saying it's all fine
AKA it's a zero or a one or two out of
10 you're in deep [__] because you've
lost Trust of the board and that's when
the seeds start to sprout of are you the
right person to run this company and if
you have a board that has say in you
being AKA you didn't structure in a way
where you could actually get ousted you
better be real careful
AKA forget about overpromise under
deliver under under under promise to
your board and overd deliver yes uh uh
100% and totally with you Gary I'll even
raise you one which is like even if it's
like you know you're you're preing Brad
news whenever anything you know it's
like I think it's going to be a little
controversial or you know people will
have different opinions on or anything I
do I do what I call the rounds which is
like I text I call all the board members
one-on-one and I say hey you know I want
to give you a heads up at the board
meeting I'm G to bring up you know such
and such and I wanted to get your you
know I want to preview this with you
before you know it's a group setting so
you can tell me what you think you know
blah blah blah and and it makes them
feel special it makes them feel
connected you know they can tell you
things that they may not want to say in
front of Seven other board members you
know Etc and it's incredible amount of
work like you know to call seven people
eight people and have the same
conversation you know to to to do that
but it's that work that instills the
trust so that by the time the actual
board meetings happen everybody already
knows what's going on it's it's been so
it's been quote unquote sold before you
even had meeting totally and and I like
when my board members zone out in board
meetings and like they're bored and
they're like we've seen this like I I
actually people like my exec teams
always like come out of these board
meetings go I don't they I Henry were
they interested do they you know do they
care and I'm like that that I'm like oh
my God I'm I'm managing the board so
well when they're like enough we get it
already like like that means I've
overdone it I've overc communicated
everything there's no surprises like
yeah when the board is literally bored
uh like I've done my job well by the way
get your board bored is like a a book on
managing the board it's definitely a
real blog post hen um what's the biggest
mistake you made in 134 15 16 as a
leader that you're better at I talk a
lot about me being better at cander I
used to struggle with delivering bad
news because I have a disease that's
called I love my employees and I mean it
I love people you get you're getting to
know me a little bit here I'm just them
who I am like I really like people and I
screw up and I've gotten way better and
especially last three years I wrote a
book that touched on it aggressively I
talk about it my content more cander was
my kryptonite if I asked you 2013 145
Henry versus 20223 going into 2024 Henry
what's been the biggest Gap you've
closed as a
leader yeah well I have two thoughts one
on the on the cander side I've always
had a problem with the kind of the
cander cander radical cander thing I I
remember remember talking to Kim about
it and you know I I love Kim I think
he's fantastic but I always said you
know the problem I have with the book is
it's a it's a one-size fits all like
radical cander kind of works with no
matter who you're talking to you know
whether you're talking to a shy you know
23y old first job employee or like your
25-year veteran CFO that you've worked
with for six years right like it's it's
the same and and everything I know about
people is uh know your audience like how
you talk to them yeah yeah it
matters to your point Kim's awesome like
by the way I call it kind cander at
vainer media because I think radical
people feel like oh let me give you the
purest form of it which I actually think
seeps into people's real struggle with
cander which is they don't don't they
don't deliberate with enough empathy
compassion sympathy and
context totally I I would even go so
here's the I I do this all the time in
my management training right you go like
go okay so manager's working with the
their employee and the employee not
doing great uh in the manager's View and
the manager says okay you know so I'm
going to deliver the feedback and they
basically say you know employee you know
I don't think you're doing great and you
know I always ask you know the the the
most important thing to figure out is it
doesn't matter yet what you think what
what matters is what the employee thinks
right if the employee agrees with you
and is like I don't think I'm doing
great either that's a very different
conversation that if the employee like I
don't know what you're talking about I'm
crushing it and so the the first thing
to say after you say hey I don't think
you're doing great is what do you think
right and if they're like uh I don't
think I'm doing great either you're like
amazing so let's talk about how how I
can help right that becomes a
collaborative discussion uh of of fixing
it if the employees like uh uh I'm
crushing it I don't know what you're
talking about that's a very different
conversation right and then the second
you know if you go down the decision
tree the second thing managers always do
is um I say okay what do you say if they
say manager you're you're wrong I'm
crushing it I don't know what you're
talking about the manager will always
what they do is they they double down
they're like no no here here's all the
reasons why you're not doing good right
and I'm always like that's the losing
battle never do that right and my my
advice is always to say to the to the to
the employee I said oh amazing I'm so
glad you think you're doing well why why
do you think I don't think you're doing
well and and right so so you lead with
curiosity um because that's the thing to
figure out right it's not it's not the
the question to solve is not if the
employee is doing well or not the
question to solve is why why are you
seeing the same thing differently that's
the question to solve you know it's I
love you for that because we do
something here where I train my leaders
to say hey Henry in my subjective
opinion from my
purview which is all I can really rely
on and the data that I've gathered from
others I believe you're not crushing it
instead of like this is definitive fact
right and that really triggers people
because we know this a lot of managers
are wrong lot times are right lot of
times are wrong by the way I watched
managers for years give feedback to
people only because they wanted to keep
them down because they knew that person
was better than them totally 100%
idiosyncratic manager bias I think is
one of the worst uh diseases in an
organiz I couldn't agree more brother
yeah let real quick just to almost like
we interrupt for this commercial break I
really do love your product and so one
more time who who's listening here
should really discover Carta and why and
what does it do and where should they go
oh thanks for letting me do that I
really you know what's funny people I've
done this podcast a long time I never do
this but I wanted to do this for two
reasons I wanted a steak and potatoes
meeting which we're doing and honestly I
really think I'm about to help a lot of
people who listen to the show so I'm
being a little selfish and I'm thrilled
that it's good for
you yeah thank you so uh you know we
serve uh uh uh two types of customers so
one is if if you're an entrepreneur
running a company uh whether it's you
know a two-person startup whether it's
uh uh an LLC you know um small business
in the midwest like we have products for
you basically we want to help you manage
your your shareholders um your
stakeholders your employees so so we'll
we'll help you on on understand the
capital structure of your business that
that's what we do for for entrepreneurs
uh and then on the other side if you're
a
a venture fund manager or a private
Equity Fund manager will help you manage
your your fund and like Gary you're
you're a customer of ours you know for
your Venture fund um and we help people
like you you know I have this kind of
view of the world which is you know
America as a country we're like great at
producing um accountants you know and
lawyers and doctors like we're really
good at that um but we're really bad at
producing entrepreneurs like we just
don't we we don't produce them what
happens to them G to show you something
Henry that is a
this is my report card look at my class
rank it looks like mine yeah about that
you and I have started a company from
scratch with 2,000 employees knock on
wood are doing extremely well the I mean
it was literally the 11th worst student
in my class you're absolutely right we
now look I actually would argue a
different point I actually think America
is great at creating entrepreneurs which
is why it creates entrepreneurs in the
macro in the micro AKA School system and
like a lot of social norms we have the
inspiration for entrepreneurship here we
put it on a pedestal there's plenty of I
was born in a place where we demonized
it it was called the USSR I was born in
the Soviet Union you know and so I think
that but to your point we definitely
don't teach it you're either born with
it and you fight the system you're the
one that really bothers me which I think
is what you're touching on you're born
with it and the system and your parents
take you out of it which is the
devastating one some of the greatest
entrepreneurs were talked out of it to
be lawyers you know and do that crushes
me um so I I I love where you're going
with that so go ahead well well to your
point yeah you know entrepreneurs in in
America we're you know we're celebrated
but but we're the aberration right we're
the weird ones to your point your report
card shows it right you're you're the
exception not not the rule uh and uh
that that's why I say like it's it's a
weird thing and and it just goes from
like the way the way we we teach school
right School is taught you go
Kindergarten first grade second gr you
know 11th grade you know freshman in
college and then you become a a junior
associate and then a senior associate
and it just there's a ladder and
Entrepreneurship there's no ladder it
even goes to like the way we do school
like tests right it's so weird tests you
start at 100% uh it's bounded and then
everything you get wrong you get you get
dinged and you go down as opposed to you
start at zero and then everything you
get right you go up uh and it's
unbounded because that's what
entrepreneurship is you start at zero
and you go up and it's unbounded um but
but that's everything we're taught in
school is the opposite what um what have
you Noti here's a good one a lot of
people for that you have 2,000 employees
I have 2,000 employees what does a
middle manager call it a director
wanting to be a VP everybody's got
different terminology but like what does
a middle manager in your company do to
take it to the next level and H and you
could be very specific of how it works
at CA
and how do you feel that maps to advice
that I think we have a ton of middle
managers great you know six figure
salary doing their thing but really do
want to grow and from a CEO's point of
view from a real entrepreneur and been
around the kind of tech companies that
are really there's a lot of companies
that fit the profile of what you do and
and and a lot of them are coming and are
being built now and just and even a lot
of them had to be at this point of the
size of your and my company and that was
30 40 years ago but middle manager what
are some of the things you're seeing
that help somebody Propel to a a VP or
SVP or EVP or take those next two steps
double their salary more responsibility
more challenges enjoy their day-to-day
more what what are some of the cliche
things you think about when you're
trying to help a middle manager grow
yeah I you know I was um like when I was
18 I I enlisted in the Marines uh and I
I went through kind of Officer candidate
school and college and all that and some
somebody said to me um he goes you know
the the the difference between M
military life and civilian life is in
the military you're judged by the the
worst thing you did and in the civilian
life you're judged by the best thing you
did and in in most companies middle
managers are judged by the the worst
thing they did right your job is to not
not mess up right and and to like do the
right thing and and be be popular and
liked and you know all that kind of
stuff and not piss off your boss and you
know not have any dings um and and that
leads to a very defensive you know
middle management core uh and and really
a calcification of an
organization uh I hope at Carta uh we're
a company where we measure middle
managers on the best thing best things
they've done and so if if that's true uh
that really means like we forgive
mistakes we don't care about that kind
of stuff what we really want to see is a
middle manager Bend The Arc of Carta
right like a middle manager just like
they may may do six things that don't
work out but boy that seventh thing that
they did WOW right like that gets on my
radar like I'm like who who was that
person that was in that meeting what did
they just do bring that person back to
my office I want to hear more about it
100% um and and and but that's really
hard it's really hard to build and and
it's hard for them not to fear the
ramifications of shining most middle
managers are scared to shine because
they know when they leave it becomes
political and their boss BP whatever are
like what the [__] was that that's right
and they think and they think that
person can get them out before you and I
can get them up that's right it it's
threatening right because their boss is
like one if my middle man if if my
manager you know that works for me uh
makes a mistake that's a reflection on
me so I'm going to punish that and then
if they actually do something
amazing right uh what does that make me
look like like uh they they're better
than I am and so so that's why middle
management is such a like an I would
almost describe it it's like the
oppressed know uh middle class of of
organizations and and creating a dynamic
uh middle Management Corp I think is one
of the biggest challenges of running a a
growing
organization I couldn't agree
more um um what have we not touched on
in the last seven or eight
minutes uh you know on the on the scale
and operational side you're you're sort
of talking about the um what I would
have done differently you know and how
things are different from like the the
first five years years versus the the
second five years of this company and I
would say you know the the the the job
changes quite a bit for for the CEOs
that are out there that are thinking
about early stage uh versus versus late
stage and you know there's this kind of
inflection point where I used to be able
to keep the whole uh company in my head
like I I used to know the whole business
in my head like I knew everything that
was happening uh and there there becomes
this inflection point where I feel like
I don't know anything that's happening
and it's like you know I also describe
it as you know when I talk to early
stage Founders uh nothing happens unless
you make it happen right that's that's
what it means to be an early stage
founder it's like you you are the
Catalyst you you create the energy of
the organization and then you get to you
know the scale urac G and like things
just start happening and you're like why
are these things happening right like
like I don't want things to happen and
they happen let me ask question this is
a good one because for the hundred
people in the next year and the
thousands over the years that list
listen to this for the 2,000 plus
employees like you and
I I'm G to ask you a question how many
not just your direct report the SE
Suite how many family members do you
have in the 2000 that are your eyes and
ears they might be a director they might
be an Ops they might be an HR I just
want I'm curious what your answer is
when I say family members you know
exactly what I'm saying the [__]
homies the one that eyes and ears the
the double agents like the ones that are
really helping you mitigate or get
clarity on all this [__] to your point I
think we're opening an office I didn't
know about that I'm like beside myself
about from a meeting this morning dead
serious a physical office um how many of
those do you have of 2000 right now go
yeah uh probably two dozen yeah um I
should have more uh and but not a bad
number not a bad I would I would say two
dozen 24 I would
say I would say I have 40 and I would
like another 12 as well and but I got I
have a company that started with a bunch
of kids that have worked here their
whole life we're only 14 years old
similar to you and a little bit older
and I think you know actually so you're
what 10 years old now yep how many
people have worked there for eight years
or
more uh less than less than 15 got it we
got a little bit luckier and I make
sense Equity you you had different
things that probably triggered that we
got really lucky with our 11 plus of
that 14e run there's enough that allows
me to have more of them anyway not to
lose the final minutes here everyone
who's listening make as many family
members as you can if you plan on
growing big big but remember to be a
family member that requires you putting
in the work for them to take you in as
family to be able to have what we're
both talking about which is very needed
at scale yes to totally and so knowing
like I just have you know someone that
uh you know is in is in London and I'm
going to London uh next week you know to
kind of Vis the office and you know I
have my person there and I called called
her and I'm like hey tell me what's
really going on over there you know I I
get the reports I I get it through the
chain of command but like tell me on the
ground like what's what's really
happening and it it's like super uh
super powerful and having those people
uh is super important there's also this
kind of you know you know this because
you're the the founder uh CEO as well as
I am there's this big difference I I
talk to Executives about this all the
time you know what's the difference
between working for a Founder CEO versus
a professional
CEO night day yeah hold on I be
inappropriate like just there's nothing
is a bigger change in the history of a
organization that's destined to be big
than the day the founder CEO she or he
leaves nothing is a bigger day that's
how different it is in the history of
the company public IPL
nothing totally it's a completely
different culture Dynamic you know and
and just the the the the the way that
you work like we've had terrible success
bringing Executives in that have never
worked for a Founder CEO before uh and
then they work for me and they they just
think I'm a maniac understandably like
compared to every you know CEO that they
worked for they're like God Henry is
just is impossible like how do I work
with this guy and then you you work with
you know Executives that have worked
with founder CEOs and they're like okay
Henry's just a he's just a normal
founder CEO like that's how that's how
these people roll um it's such a
different different
framework paring shocks my friend what
what things of business or or Carta or
startup or pop you want to talk about
Travis Kelsey and Taylor Swift you know
like every other freaking human on earth
by the way there's no more cliche New
York Jets thing my real passion my true
love then the at the height of this
Taylor Swift Kelce thing the Jets are
playing on Sunday Night National
Football the most watch game not even
Monday night anymore Sunday night
Taylor's gonna be in the building 10
million people that have never watched a
football game are GNA watch because of
all this hype and the Jets are at the
low low point maybe they're franchise
with the hype of Aaron Rogers and the
Achilles and we're not playing well this
is the most Jets game ever
totally anyway two minutes on anything
you know actually let me say it this way
you were thinking about this
podcast what did we not touch on that
you either wanted to touch on or thought
we might touch on you know what I'm
excited about uh talking with you Gary
is I I do a lot of podcasts you know in
in my industry you know we do you know
we're talking Venture you know and so on
and you know one of the um the things I
I spend a lot of time talking about we
we call it crate ownership right I have
this kind of view of the world that you
know um labor used to be surf Dum where
you were sort of you were you know you
were legally free but economically
indentured I think we're in the era of
payroll today where you people sell time
for money um uh and I I think the the
future of of Labor is is really going to
be an ownership era you know and I think
you know the Futures here it's just not
evenly distributed and we see it in in
Tech and you're starting to see it in
other Industries you know and and um
entertainment and sports you know the
PLL professional lacrosse league gives
Equity to to players starting to see it
in other you know the NBA starting to
think about it you're seeing in other
Industries and so one of the things that
you know excited is you have a broader
audience outside of of tech is you know
can we start catalyzing more companies
thinking about ownership and employee
ownership uh as a way of of compensation
so that the next uh era of of Labor will
be an ownership uh ownership one I think
that's right brother especially if you
nerd out on the blockchain and what that
technology will enable and really
understand not the not the speculation
of the nft market or the hype of the
cryptocurrencies like if you really
understand what the blockchain will do
for the thesis you have it is the
underlying technology enabler of that
guaranteed
truth 100% yeah I enjoy this my friend
great job Gary thanks so much so much
fun thank you one more time where should
everybody go to check out your company
which I think a lot of people should be
using uh card.com cta.com thank you and
everybody you know this I don't go for
the hard push and you can say see he
wasn't looking for the push I was
looking for him to push I think a lot of
you need this because you know in the
same way I'm pushing you to make 30
minute meetings 15 we didn't get to this
one hour meetings being 30 minute
meetings not we don't need 21 people in
this meeting we need 13 everyone's like
oh I'm stretched I'm like what about
managing your time and so same here this
to me is a Savor of Time Versus the way
you're doing it and doing it better so
anyway congrats I I'm I've been very
impressed for a long time from Far Henry
and I'm I'm thrilled we stumbled on each
other I'm thrilled you took the invite
to be on the show and I love this time
together yeah super thank you Gary
thanks so
[Music]
much